quella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi dio sono fa vj e siamo su
avvicinati alla finestra che si sentono
i grilli simulator piaciuto meraviglioso
non seriamente comunque a parte questo
non ci sono altri effetti sonori
fantastico perché sarebbe un gioco dove
a questa è casa mia a nel senso è così
piccola cioè non c'è nient'altro ci sono
la stanza da letto
l'utilità di questa stanza in mezzo ma
la spiegate prima o poi vero siamo
ragazzi surel o nei board che è un gioco
dove ci sono i grilli questi qua
c'eravamo cisiano è un gioco ragazzi
dove non ho ben capito che cosa bisogna
fare però nei tuoi vuol dire ciao vicino
quindi io deduco che io debba andare a
parlare con il mio vicino che tra
l'altro ha una casa che è leggermente
più grossa della mia è sicuramente ci
sono più stanze mi dà un fastidio i
grilli comunque non ha veramente
fastidio
salve signor vicino ha lasciato la porta
aperta gliela chiudo che sono entrano i
grilli a madonna che porta è questa ma
spero ci vuole entrare su paura vabbè le
porte sono chiuse quindi non rimane che
cosa è successo a facce ragazze
dell'accoglienza si presenta in casa tua
ti chiude le porte perché seconde menta
lasciarle aperte sono morto è
semplicemente mi ha riportato a casa mia
sculacciato ed è uscito il sole la
mattina cosa è successo rispetto a prima
perché cup per perché è un [ __ ]
tostapane in mano come non si va a casa
dei vicini a mani vuote
portiamo una bottiglia d'acqua bene
salve signor vicino allora adesso che
cela parliamo scusi si no
sir vicino mi sono caga tissimo
bruttissimo sta cosa non me l'aspettavo
mai doma che provincia e dalla vita
frustrato di merda uno vuole vedere la
partita insieme ai vicino per per
socializzare ma la [ __ ] niente c'è
il vicino che mi aggredisce punto non
c'è altro non capisco chi nuovo la
partita
no no no via addestrare le merda
qual è il problema lo so niente non
capisco c'è giuro è vabbè la madonna più
entro piano in casa sua in teoria non
dovrebbe scoprirmi in teoria è la
madonna ma chiusi a chiave piuttosto
torno a casa mia e vabbè stava andando a
casa deficiente
ah ok perfetto ora gun di giorni non ho
mai giocato una roba così [ __ ]
non so se ci riesco almeno ci prova
calmi calmi calmi sta guardando la tv
calmi
un sistema moderno totti 6 anche
abbastanza ordinato spiegami perchè sei
psicopatico la bottiglia tra sei presa è
lurido pezzente vedi che alla fine va
beh sì ma sei paranoico fratello c'è
spiegami questa porta da sull'esterno
acer vi rendete conto del problema che
poi alla fine essendo così psicopatico
lui non capisco perchè io devo insistere
[Musica]
vade retro vicino
peccato sopra ci sono le videocamere ho
capito prima aveva fatto a sgamar mi sto
deficiente efficiente coperchi di bidoni
o trota torcia votato no no e no no sono
stato io e se senti il casinò perfetto o
michiara difficile a non farmi beccare
magari mentre cerco di andare a vedere
cosa c'è in casa perfetto se perché
stamattina assi su una trappola
nola vedo niente avuto migliaia di me ma
perchè ma perché ma che i problemi
mentali ai c'è un frigo che blocca una
porta bene abita l'altro non è la stessa
casa di prima perché prima c'era una
porta exit adesso non c'è più ecco cosa
certa dentro che non avevo capito prima
un cesso abbia giustamente essendo il
bagno non facciamo domande che è meglio
un'altra porta che non ha idea di dove
con dubbi
una caldaia era quella di fuori perfetto
del martello un marte pre prendi il
martello prendi martello spacca al vetro
ed essi snack e allora sei stronzo è
passato il martello allora non passi tu
è aperta vuol dire caffè e allora c'è un
problema di fondo io sono uscito dal
retro qua qua c'è un vetro
qual è il problema vabbè che ansia
allora niente cosa serve st stanza
inutile posso nascondermi sotto il letto
però il problema è che non capisco cosa
serve visto che la stanza completamente
vuota sotto i quadri non è che devo
[ __ ] le cose e devo portarla a casa
mia e non lo sapevo o [ __ ] un
caravaggio perfetto
rientriamo un secondo dal retro che ho
capito come si fa sta cosa che la
martella equa ragazzi prova vedere se
disco a sfondare l'altra porta quindi
questa qui
il martello la famiglia niente non ce
l'ho fatta la ragazza ancora caravaggio
erano lanciato sei ripreso questo ed
efficiente prova dei mitra i problemi
che non ha messo un lucchetto sto
stronzo 7 88 246 parte di noi deve
essere un codice la foto partner cacia
la chiave la chiave veloce non me la
usano mela usano altri mandela bay
ragazzi c'è di tutto c'è un bene ma
adesso sta fino alla porta ragazzo il
problema
dico di mandello su per il culo cosa
vuoi fare caselli a niente ma ucciso c'è
qualcosa di strano che non capisco è
come se stesse nascondendo qualcosa se
ogni volta si blinda sempre di più quale
problemi sono a casa mia non puoi
l'annunzio dai sono a casa mia dove puoi
toccare cosa migliore vicenza a si è
diventato dove è andato è diventato
giorno tra l'altro bellissimo almeno
vedo dove sto andando dio mio prima non
vedevo niente
ma c'è un'altra palco mentre in casa
ragazzi quale problema non posso ci può
mettermi sotto il letto che prima certo
bug incredibile esatto non posso uscire
dai fammi uscire direttamente fuori
dalla stanza
[ __ ] in tre ragazzini mi rimane
che suonare il campanello è l'unica è
l'unica maniera che ho per entrare dover
suonare il campanello correre
velocissimo che si porta dietro pure la
sedia tanto e sono entrato in casa va
bene credo sia aperta della fota in
teoria perfetto giacché tattica
veloce veloce perché sono sempre chiuse
ecco perché la stanza da letto
irraggiungibile professione cose davanti
non le posso spostare tipo
no non posso spostava beh allora ok
così dovrebbe essere in teoria il
martello perfetto come tinta successo io
non c'è nessuno zio questa e malvagità
paura come faccio a tirarlo via
dall'iraq e devo far cadere qualcosa non
ho capito come cazzo pieri porta c'è un
piede di porco e non lo sapevo c'è un
[ __ ] piede di porco o eccomi in
chiaro
fammi capire cosa sinistra stanza che ci
sono le cose che volano ma in teoria se
sfascio la finestra dovrei riuscire ad
entrare quad ok ci siamo ragazzi sono
dentro mi spiegate perchè sta stanza
compratore si è iniziato tutto il mouse
grazie grazie
guarda faq va dai sei serio io buono
marecchia salve se qualcuno mi spiega
che cosa minchia sto giocando bene prego
se cambia adesso cambiata la casa ha
cambiato la disposizione di tutta a casa
ma qual è il problema è che trick
non si apre niente non si apre
non posso andare di soprano chiuso il
ceo ci sia la pista porta magrin fino
sotto il letto perfetto nell'armadio
infilati stata letta ce la fai una sedia
dio mio
o la va o la spacca ragazzo l'aveva
spacca la nostra h lava lava che culo
anche ci passi molto idiota perfetta
come è arrivata in un seconda [ __ ]
eh vabbè mi stavo infilando sotto il
letto subito mi sarei infilato niente
arrivato subito va beh secondo me basta
perché ho apprezzato tanto molto bello
almeno una lezione l'abbiamo imparata
mai rompere il cazzo ai vicini oppure
fate come faccio io che metto la musica
e dm alle 2 di notte
ragazzi miei concludo che episodio è
stato alquanto strano soprattutto quando
è diventato gigante il tizio aspetto che
esca la versione ufficiale perché la sta
facendo e sono curioso di vedere che
cosa esce fuori visto che giocò mostrano
però misterioso la cosa mi piace sopra
gli anni io adoro i giochi misteriosi
non lo so perché spero che vi diamo 100
ragazzi consente il mio bisogno sul
momento non mi piace ha già piace di
facebook che coniuga data notizia nei
servizi idrici che diamo prossimo vito
dei ragazzi